touchdown confirmed perseverance
faithfully
on the surface of mars and historic
moment for nasa
the first ever color video of a
spacecraft landing
on mars a planet more than 200 million
kilometers from ours
it's been what we've been dreaming about
for years so and let me
give you a quick warning to not blink
because things go really fast here
you can see that you can get a sense
really of how violent that parachute
deploy and inflation are
the 2.7 billion dollar perseverance
rover
is on a mission to explore the red
planet for ancient
signs of life it was a nail-biting
moment for scientists
who had to wait several minutes to
receive the signal
that it had successfully landed on the
gizero crater
that's said to be an ancient riverbed
that's carried water
billions of years ago it's not just
video of thursday's landing that nasa
had released
this is the microphone that was part of
the edl camera
system i invite you now to if you would
like to close your eyes
and just imagine yourself sitting on the
surface of mars
it will take a few weeks for the rover
to get rolling on its heavy duty wheels
the team will first check all systems
update
software and test the instruments it
will allow us to do further
in-depth checkouts of the instrument we
have our coring drill in the center
our pixel and sherlock instruments
mounted to the side and that black tank
is to support the gut the gas dust
removal tool
which will remove dust from the surfaces
that we will be inspecting later and in
about a month
a drone named ingenuity would attach to
explore the surface
nasa has also pieced together six
pictures to create a panoramic of the
dusty martian landscape
surrounding the rover the perseverance
will soon explore the river delta
that ran into an ancient lake there in
the dust and sediment
scientists are hoping to find fossils
that prove
life once existed on the red planet
laura bardemani al jazeera